رسميا انطلاقه كاس العالم اليوم في قطر
بعد ازاله حضره من تويتر ترامب لا ارى
سببا للعوده ممثله ايرانيه تتحدث سلطان
بفيديو بدون حجاب هذه الاخبار وغيرها
نقولها لكم من قناه العربيه اهلا بكم
افتتحت قطر رسميا في استاد البيت في
العاصمه الدوحه اول بطوله لكاس العالم
لكره القدم في الشرق الاوسط وسط حضور هائل
من المشجعين وكبار زعماء العالم وما زال
حفله الافتتاح بين التقاليد القطريه
والعربيه والثقافه العالميه و يتمحور
رسائله حول التقارب بين الشعوب البشريه
والتغلب على الاختلافات من خلال الانسانيه
والاحترام وانطلقت منافسات المونديال
رسميا بلقاء الافتتاح بين قطر البلد
المضيف والاكوادور صاحب المركز الرابع في
تصفيات امريكا الجنوبيه
بعد ساعه فقط من اعاده المالك الجديد
لتويتر ايرون ماسك حساب الرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب وتفعيله
اقراي سبب للعوده الى المنصه مشيدا لمنصته
الجديده تروس سوشيال وقال ترامب في كلمه
عبر الفيديو خلال الاجتماع السنوي للحزب
الجمهوري في لاس فيغاس ان منصه العصفور
الازرق لديه العديد من المشكلات والحسابات
الوهميه والمزيفه
بعد ما نشرت الفنانه الايرانيه تيران علي
دوسطي فيديو ظهرت فيه دون حجاب الممثله
هان كما قضياني المقيمه بايران تنشر هي
الاخرى فيديو من دون حجاب على صفحتها على
انستغرام وانكتبت الفنانه الحاصله على
العديد من الجوائز العالميه في تعليق على
المقطع المصور ان هذه ربما هي اخر مشاركه
لها على صفحتها في اشاره لامكانيه
اعتقالها كما حصل مع العديد من الفنانين
الذين ظهروا سابقا على وسائل التواصل
الى الجزائر هذه المره النيابه العامه في
البلاد طلبت انزال عقوبه الاعدام بحق 74
متهما بتعذيب المواطن جمال بن اسماعيل
واحرقه حيا والتنكيل بجثته خلال اشتعال
الحرائق في منطقه القبائل في الجزائر قبل
حوالي عام وهذا بداعي افتعاله الحرائق
يذكر ان جمال بن اسماعيل كان يبلغ من
العمر 38 عاما حين ذهبت كمتطوع للمساعده
في اطفاء الحرائق الغابات في منطقه
القبائل واثارت قضيته تعاطفا واسعا بعد
قتله بطريقه
وفي خبرنا الاخير حادثه طريفه شهدتها
مدينه بوكوره الاندونيسيه بعدما زيف رجل
وفاته وهذا للتهرب من ديونه الا ان حيلتهم
كشفت بعدما صور فيديو له وهو يتحرك داخل
التابوت الشرطه الاندونيسيه قالت ان
التحقيقات في هذه الحادثه اظهرت ان الرجل
لفق وفاته بمساعده زوجته انه سيتم استجواب
الزوجين بعد التاكد من سلامه صحه الزوج